resident evil code veronica is an
overlooked gem of the series and i think
if you've never played it it's about
time you do no matter how much i play
classic resident evil games returning to
them is never a warm and fuzzy
experience it's addicting but terrifying
tight corners zombies jump scares tank
controls and the dread of losing hours
of progression over one mistake but
these were the things that helped rocket
the resident evil series to worldwide
success and even though i was terrified
to sleep most nights after playing i
mean i was like 10 years old i loved
every minute of it in this video i want
to talk about code veronica and why it's
not only so great but important before
the series story went backwards with
resident evil 0 code veronica had
several loose ends to tie up from its
prequels resident evil 1 through 3. in
fact code veronica was almost part 3.
during its development capcom was
transitioning through a new generation
of gaming hardware originally an
exclusive title for the sega dreamcast
code veronica was a result of a failed
resident evil 2 port for the sega saturn
once the developers realized that the
port wouldn't work they shifted to a new
project for the upcoming dreamcast
instead resident evil code veronica
despite the excitement of the all-new
dreamcast making this game an exclusive
title was a hard ask considering the
playstation 2 was just around the corner
soon enough resident evil 4 came along
and changed everything however just
before the dawn of this new
over-the-shoulder action survival era
there were a few games that bid farewell
to the series as we once knew it despite
these games also getting their start on
6th gen hardware they were quickly
overshadowed by resident evil 4 and the
turning point it created for the beloved
capcom series i think for this big
reason code veronica never truly had its
chance to shine in the sun and that
needs to change but first a little
backstory
[Music]
taking place three months after the
events of resident evil 3 nemesis we
catch up with claire redfield still on
the hunt for her missing brother chris
claire ends up in a secluded island
prison run by the umbrella corporation
the events of resident evil 2 have
hardened our protagonist as seen by the
explosive opening where claire dodges
enemy guards and even evades a minigun
mounted to a helicopter a scene reused
in the second resident evil film two
years later
they're the same picture it's a far cry
from resident evil 2's opening where
she's almost eaten and accidentally
killed within the first few minutes
don't shoot down
you okay
boy if you don't some of the biggest
takeaways with code veronica are its
story characters and environments
pulling players away from raccoon city
for the first time is unsettling but
makes for such a memorable experience
from the start despite all the terrors
that lie ahead the environments in code
veronica have held up well over the last
20 years the rockford island prison in
the game's first half is dark and full
of secrets much like the spencer mansion
or the rpd in previous games you soon
figure out that the island is more than
a prison in training ground the prison
belongs to the ashford family a royal
family whose dynasty came to a crumbling
end at rockford
the game's opening isn't all doom and
gloom though that's because code
veronica was blessed with the
introduction of steve burnside a fellow
prisoner escapee shut up claire and
steve find each other at the start of
the game and team up to escape well sort
of
i don't want you following me
steve wears his heart on his sleeve and
you'll never know what you'll get with
each encounter you learn that he and his
father were imprisoned at rockford after
attempting to sell information about an
umbrella to the public his flashy
attitude terrible flirting skills and
tight outfit make him an easy target but
at 17 years old he's just a boy an
emotionally charged boy who runs around
with gaudy golden luger handguns and
telling claire that she can't count on
anyone in this world and that even guns
are more reliable than humans he is a
mess but one i grew to love over the
years or you know love to hate shut up
i don't want to talk about it
in the wii title umbrella chronicles the
story is retold with a more level-headed
steve damn girl which is fine but
underwhelming compared to the steve i
know and love
i so want to enjoy
this
that uh joyful giggle is from none other
than alfred ashford one of the game's
main antagonists his backstory is deep
and disturbing in short he was an
unplanned clone created by his father
alexander alexander created this clone
using dna from a former family matriarch
named veronica to create a prodigy child
and bring back the glory to the ashford
name however during the process he
accidentally created twins alexia and
alfred with notably less intelligence
than his clone sister alfred grew up in
alexia's shadow despite this alfred
worshipped alexia and the two grew up
together at an umbrella antarctic base
in harmony
claire meets alfred with his back
against the wall calling her out for
being a spy and blaming her for the
bombing run on rockford island that had
happened mere moments ago when it was
actually albert wesker that was
responsible
that's right wesker returns in his first
appearance after his death in resident
evil 1. having injected himself with the
strain of the t-virus that night at the
spencer mansion not only was he able to
survive the tyrant attack but he became
a superhuman in the process his role in
code veronica is way more menacing now
that he transcends human strength and
it's also very over the top his
superpowers make him hit harder super
jump and give his eyes a red glow claire
is the real hero here but wesker's
melodramatic performance as a superhuman
is one to remember and who could forget
alexia herself at this point i've
mentioned alexia quite a bit but code
veronica does a great job of building
her up and surrounding her backstory and
mystery now we all know having a clone
sibling in video games doesn't tend to
work out in many cases
and the ashfords are no exception this
awful little uh home movie claire finds
is a 45 second red flag alfred even uses
this as his computer's boot up screen
and the older these two got the worse it
became i won't give away too much
because i really want you to play this
for yourself but let's just say the
relationship between these two is weird
it's just weird
another special appearance is chris
redfield okay i know he's on the cover
of the box but when i first played this
i felt like his arrival would never
happen so it still feels special to me
chris is back and on the hunt for claire
his dramatic opening climbing up
rockford island makes for a badass
return you really start to understand
why he hates rocks
his relationship with wesker rears its
ugly head and code veronica's story
which is a treat despite the two wanting
to kill each other after what happened
in resident evil 1 you guys are idiots
and how could we forget the reunion of
claire and chris
claire began her journey into the
resident evil series with the sole
purpose of finding her brother the
ending of resident evil 2 revealed a lot
about the umbrella corporation the
g-virus raccoon city and its lousy mayor
and way more but while she survived
claire's mission was incomplete and
chris's whereabouts remained unknown the
two finally crossed paths at the
antarctic base and worked together to
try to stop wesker and the ashfords and
contain the new veronica virus
if you played resident evil 1-4 and
skipped code veronica you missed the
first time seeing the redfields together
you blew it
okay now that we've talked about code
veronica's story and main characters
let's talk about the actual gameplay
that also makes this game so great
the theme you're hearing is one of the
most terrifying melodies that represents
alexia and alfred much like resident
evil 2 it's music tracks like this that
are burned into my memory purely
associated with the terror of alfred and
his disturbing family mansion
[Music]
being one of the last classic resident
evil titles the formula of survival
horror with fixed camera perspective has
really been polished here and has aged
very well in a post resident evil 4
world
the puzzles aren't too hard which lets
you focus on surviving and the story but
they're peppered in just enough to break
up the gameplay like before all the
files and diaries found can nudge you in
the right direction if you're feeling a
little lost
now between you and me i remember going
into a gamestop and finding one answer
to a puzzle that i was looking for that
had boggled me for weeks after i found
the answer i was looking for i left
without buying the guide and i felt like
i robbed the place
and i remember writing down this stolen
intel in my game's manual which i still
have
wow richie that puzzle wasn't hard at
all couldn't figure that one out on your
own bud
little known fact this was the last
resident evil title that included
weapons using their real world names
like the ak-47 and calico m100
submachine gun some were modified and
not all of these are entirely accurate
but cool nonetheless thanks time morgan
ink ribbon all that being said this
game's a little hard i personally
remember putting this game down for
quite a while because i simply couldn't
get through it now i know i'm not the
best resident evil player but while most
agree that it's not necessarily easy
it's definitely worth it there's also
this unlockable mode called battle game
that lets you take revenge on every
living creature this game has to offer
you can play as claire steve chris and
for the first time you can even play as
wesker after revisiting this mode years
later i have to commend how nicely it's
held up especially in first person mode
this game is full of surprises creepy
world building and even new enemies like
the bandersnatch a rejected warped
tyrant that can slap your face from
across the room fortunately this game is
pretty damn accessible it's available on
just about everything from the xbox
series x original dreamcast version and
everything in between almost too many
options honestly the original dreamcast
version is simply called resident evil
code veronica but everything after that
is the special edition called code
veronica x it's got a few more
pre-rendered cutscenes and even a new
haircut for steve for some reason i
originally played it on the playstation
2 and when they released an hd version
in 2011 i wanted in after downloading it
and reliving this awesome experience
once again i was surprised to learn that
i played through the ps2 port and not
the hd version idiot so if you're gonna
dive in and you'd prefer the updated
aspect ratio and smoother textures be
sure to look out for that hd badge
whatever even after accidentally playing
through the ps2 port i still had an
awesome time or three aspect ratio and
all
now that i've gushed about this game for
all the world to hear i have a
confession i never played resident evil
zero i played the intro on a friend's
copy but never made it past the opening
train sequence while i generally know
what happens in the game story i know
i'm missing out big time if you've made
it to this point in the video tell me if
you think i should give it another shot
i mean i just spilled my guts over a 20
year old game i think i can do it again
thanks for watching
you